okay so I completely forgotten there was
going to be a new trailer for guardians
of the galaxy two until I woke up this
morning so I'm going to do that thing
that I do very rarely which is to do
like a proper reaction video where you
actually see me reacting to get my
immediate thoughts on no editing no
thinking about it before I start
blabbering which is obviously why it's
probably going to be a bit rambling
before I watch it I will say I'm a
little bit nervous to watch the trailer
I am very excited for this movie and
I've liked all the marketing put out so
far but the thing is with these sorts of
you know well I think it's called a
second trailer but you know this and the
teaser this in the trailer analysis at
this point everything we've seen has
been general feel isolated moments which
is also me very well usually by this
time we start getting into more actual
plot details and that's where I get
nervous because once I've already made
up my mind to see a movie I kind of like
to know less about it I love to be
surprised in the theater and if I was
the first one more self control I just
wouldn't watch the trailer but I am NOT
that person would enough self-control to
stop myself from watching it so here we
go let's see how we do oh I'm ready
[Music]
it's sort were you think in guns per
month but I guess we both doing does now
I just didn't know that so wonderfully
awkward ah ok cruise pluggy in the am
that's lovely that's a lot of goals ok I
kind of reminds me of the Nova Corps it
kind of ship
[Music]
I like that they're using this same song
again love Fleetwood Mac talk about it
boring and I'm actually liking rocket
more in this one of the feel of them
worn this one then from the last 10 sooo
cute
[Music]
sometimes the thing is searching for
your whole life it's right there by your
style all right
sterile
[Music]
listen many are yes
[Music]
after all these years I've found you mr.
hell are you I'm your dad Gator you do
not look like a living planet to me okay
well we'll see how that pans out um that
was good it was fine I did not give away
a bunch of plot which was obviously what
I said I was afraid of that didn't
happen so props to that it was mostly
more of the same in terms of giving the
general feel highlighting the characters
and it just is sort of lingered on
different moments for each of them a
little bit more which i think is a good
thing now what I mentioned about rocket
saying I like him better in this I
didn't dislike market in the first movie
he was fine but I think in some ways
Marvel wasn't entirely sure who the
breakout characters of that first movie
were going to be and I think they
expected rock it to be the real
front-runner but I think for most of us
it was group with maybe Drax as a
secondary which is not again not to say
that rocket was bad but what it looks
like here is they're putting less
emphasis on sort of him as the
wisecracker and I mean he still got some
but i like how much we saw of him
tinkering with stuff with him building
would stuff and it looks like they're
going to put more emphasis on his role
as the tech guy as opposed to you know
oh look you got this big gonna need a
little raccoon but yet you made that
joke the first one what else can he do
well he can build all this crap that
does all these crazy things that's a
that's a nice Ephesus he did a little of
that in the first one and I think that's
a good way to sort of put ad the main
emphasis on him going forward especially
as we're adding new members to the thing
and we get a little bit of nebulas vibe
I'll still be interested to see how she
fits into this I'm very glad she's back
and I'm really glad I didn't kill her
off I thought Karen Gillan I mean I
liked her anyways but I thought she was
a much more compelling general presence
than Ronan the accuser was and i just i
chalk that up to chalk that up to a
personal bias and the performance um you
know little glimpse of Kurt Russell
looking like looking like Kurt Russell
so you know that I think he looks about
how he
most of us know of that whole you know
you're not friends were family line I'm
let me add Rex put a capper at the end
of it because until he did that it felt
some but it felt very fast and furious
honestly which always has been dealing
with family family family is what's
important etcetera etcetera etcetera so
it felt a little like that so I'm glad
they were able to cap a joke on it to
sort of differentiate a little um other
than that it was it was good it gave me
more of what I was hoping to get you
know more moments more of the general
feel like I said I really like that they
use the chain the song by Fleetwood Mac
again I love that song i like i like the
marketing on these i like that they pick
that they picked a period song to be
like and this is the one where we're
doing the marketing with and last time
it was what kind of feeling now it's the
chain so I and and like I said it did
not give a ton of specific plot away I
mean we see you know this golden race of
whatever you know seems to be the ones
recruiting them but I mean that's kind
of that's going to be front end stuff
i'm pretty sure that tentacle monster
encounter is going to be one of the
first if not the first thing that we see
them do so the stuff that seems to that
they seem to have laid out is all front
end stuff and I'm always fine with the
front end of plot getting shown and
marketing its when anything that happens
after the halfway mark getting shown but
I started to get iffy so um and Emily do
were probably moments that we saw that
we're from the latter half but I don't
feel like I don't feel like I know the
plot I don't know what they're really
out to do I don't know what the
obstacles are on their way I don't know
the circumstances under which nebula and
yondu join the group and for me that's
all good I don't want to know those
things before I going because then I'm
stuck sitting there you know just seeing
how they connect to the things that I
already knew we're going to happen and
that's not how I like to watch a movie I
like to not know where it's going if
that's possible doesn't happen often but
i love it when it does so good trailer
how didn't blow me away but didn't
didn't mess up the enthusiasm i already
had so i'll take it so that'll do it for
this one guys i'll try and turn this
around
as I canvassed the reason I'm doing you
this way so i don't have to edit it so
that will wrap it up don't forget to
Like subscribe check me out on Twitter
at council of geeks give a listen to the
counsel of geek podcast available on
iTunes and stitcher and until next time
this council is adjourned